Cuál es el legado más representativo que
de joven editó 16 cuando fue sumo
pontífice un cargo que dejó hacer allá
Algunos años
bueno son varios los elementos que
efectivamente vamos a recordar de de
Benedicto como papa
me atrevería a plantear que fue el
primer papa que es capaz de poder
enfrentarse al tema de los abusos el
tema Irlanda el tema de Estados Unidos
El no tuvo problemas en enfrentar esa
situación
también empezó todo lo que es la reforma
de la curia que posteriormente
continuará el Papa Francisco y creo que
un tercer elemento y no menos importante
es ser capaz de poder acercar El
Vaticano con la gente a través de los
medios de comunicación social hay que
recordar que ahí apareció la arroba
pontifiques Por qué es tan importante
eso porque efectivamente
El Vaticano se abre yo me atrevería a
plantear que efectivamente
Benedicto 16 abre el Vaticano deja
entrar un poco de aire fresco aire que
hoy día está recibiendo fuertemente con
ventarrones el Papa Francisco
el señor Sánchez y en ese mismo sentido
Cuáles serían entonces las diferencias
entre lo que fue Benedicto 16 y ahora lo
que es el Pues el Papa Francisco primero
Qué cambios ha habido para la iglesia
desde que asumió Francisco primero
son dos personas absolutamente distintas
el Papa Benedicto es un intelectual el
Papa Benedicto escribió más de 100
libros es un hombre que tiene muchos
doctorados honoris causa es un hombre
que estuvo a cargo de la doctrina de la
fe durante más de veinte años en el
pontificado de Juan Pablo Segundo es un
hombre de su historia
es un hombre que vivió además los
embates de lo que significó la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
en cambio el Papa Francisco es distinto
el Papa Francisco además un latino
Perdón este también es un es un hombre
Alemán de acuerdo Entonces el Papa
Francisco es un hombre latín un hombre
distinto un hombre muy cercano un hombre
que efectivamente
ha seguido el conducto que dejó
instalado Benedicto para poder de alguna
otra forma comenzar a hacer algo que
suena feo pero real limpiar el Vaticano
por dentro hay una frase que dice
veredicto que a mí me queda grabada
siempre las grandes persecuciones a la
iglesia no vienen de afuera sino de los
pecados que hay dentro